intentemos calcular 3 por 32 y aquí lo
que voy a hacer es es poner la notación
poner esta anotación donde el número
mayor está arriba el 32 arriba y el
número menor en este caso el 3 está
abajo del 32 situado en el lugar de las
unidades
ahí mismo entonces ok 32 por 3 y es lo
mismo simplemente cambio la anotación
pero esencialmente dará el mismo
resultado estamos haciendo lo mismo no
importa el orden en el que multiplicas 3
por 32 es lo mismo que 32 por 3 entonces
lo que voy a hacer es lo que se hace es
este 3 este 3 va a multiplicar a cada
uno de los dígitos en 32 así que
hagámoslo entonces primero primero por
el 2 3 por 2 es igual a 6 ya lo sabes
por las tablas de multiplicar es igual a
6 y pongo al 6 en el lugar de las
unidades ahora vamos a hacer el
siguiente 3 por 3
ahora sigue este dígito 3 por 3 es igual
a 9 y como estoy multiplicando por el
número situado en el lugar de las
décimas lo pondré ahí mismo en el lugar
de las décimas ahí va el 9 entonces
terminamos 32 por 3 es igual a 96
felices todos ahora hay que hay que ser
curiosos en la vida y pregúntate por qué
funciona por qué porque es válido esto
te voy a dar una pista ok
3 por 32 es lo mismo que 3 por 30 más
3 por 2 así lo observas de esta manera
es lo mismo que se hizo acá es el mismo
proceso 3 por 2 es igual a 6 y 3 por 30
es igual a 90 90 696 y listo magia